they're hitting these functions of
displacement to get us to what on earth
is this talking about I want us to
remember at this point we have a few
equations to describe simple harmonic
motion to begin with right we know that
when we think about motion that is
centered around the origin right these
are the simplest kinds of equations of
simple harmonic motion that you can come
up with so we might start off by saying
x equals or we know there's going to be
any kind of amplitude that you like is
that what is that it's such a sign
outside it's just someone else how to
get random that's right so we know that
the average of our simple harmonic
motion can be anything you like so we
slap a coefficient at the front it
doesn't really matter which one are
actually right both in a second but you
could have either sign or you could have
cosine right we also know that our
period of that motion can be whatever
you like it could be 2 pi seconds if you
just said T or it could be 5 seconds or
24 seconds and you just change the
coefficient as necessary so it could be
n teeth now something we haven't dealt
with in heaps of detail but if you think
about your graphing you're like oh this
is not too much of a drama is if I
started out with this right a sine NT
then where does my particle object-ball
whatever where is it begin where is it
initially it's going to be at the origin
right because that's where sine begins
goes up and goes down right if I didn't
wanted to start at the origin if I say
wanted to start on one end of the motion
one extremity or on the other
I wouldn't use sine would I what would I
use instead I'll use cos we might as
well write this underneath so either of
these will start us in the middle of the
motion in the center or on the edges on
the extremities but there's no reason
why you know objects can always have to
start here or on the extremities they
could start anywhere they want right so
in order to be somewhere in between not
in the center not on the edges all you
have to do is introduce a little bit of
a shift if you put it out of phase
by some different angle okay you don't
have to draw this bit but for example
instead of sine starting off right smack
bang where I normally do right if I
shifted it over a little bit for example
I might get in a shape like this right
so that exhibits all the same things the
same amplitude will be the same period
but it starts at neither the centre of
motion nor at the extremities it kind of
starts in between and you know depending
on whatever times euro is we could have
a situation like that and that's fine
okay so here are our sort of initial
simplest equations for the displacement
of simple harmonic motion okay now in
the very first lesson we should have
noticed that if you have a look at the
velocity and the acceleration for these
things all you have to do is
differentiate a couple of times right
and what you will notice mm-hmm for each
of these is that what happens okay when
you go by the time you get to X double
dot okay when you differentiate sine it
becomes cosine when you differentiate
cosine it becomes negative sine so
you've come back to sine haven't you
right the same kind of thing happens
because if you differentiate cos the
first time you get negative sign and you
differentiate a second time to get to X
double dot and you come back to cos
don't you but the difference is you have
a minus sign out the front do you
remember that so hopefully this rings a
bell do you remember that don't ring a
bell so this guy here is special because
we've met these before when we had a
look at exponential growth and decay we
have a derivative that is not in terms
of time you notice there's no time
variable in here it's just it's just X's
right you have a derivative in terms of
the original function itself and we gave
this a special name does anyone remember
what it's called you don't really need
to know the name but it's it's nice to
be able to call it something rather than
it's that thing where you've got the
derivatives we call this a differential
equation or a de for sure anyone who's
going to do a science or an engineering
degree when they leave school you're
going to do first your math second-year
Matz and they're going to talk about DES
particularly ordinary des as opposed to
extraordinary that's not actually what
they call they're going to talk about
differential equations or what and this
is all they mean right you're relating a
derivative such as the second derivative
to the original function or in the case
of you don't have to write this down in
the case of exponential growth and decay
we had things like say DP on DT equals K
P right
so you've related the first derivative
to the original function does that make
sense so this differential equation is
really important now what we haven't
introduced here so far is when excuse me
when you have motion that's not about
the center we talked about this
yesterday but we didn't talk about the
differential equation that comes with it
right so if we have motion that has a
different center let's just call it beep
okay so we've taken our graph that looks
like say this and we've moved it really
far up or really far down or wherever
you want to go okay what will the
difference be it'd be very very subtle
between this equation and when we change
the center of motion just a teeny little
difference x equals x equals what do i
do to this graph to move it up or down
yeah I just add or subtract or whatever
a constant from the entire graph okay so
for instance I could write it like this
B plus all of this stuff that I had
before that would move it B units
upwards if B was negative I guess it
wouldn't move it downwards or I could
have it with cosine okay now you don't
need to do this twice I just want you to
once it's probably just enough I want
you to differentiate not once but twice
pick either of these it doesn't matter
you'll get the same result differentiate
them to get to acceleration and then
what differential equation do you get
I'm going to give you maybe 30 seconds
to go ahead and do both derivatives find
your velocity find your acceleration and
then see if you can state it not in
terms of T's time but see if you can
state it in terms of X I'll give you a
second to do that